it is great to welcome back to the
program richard wolff
professor emeritus of economics at my
alma mater the university of
massachusetts he taught me
introductory macroeconomics a long long
time ago
currently a visiting professor at new
school university in new york city the
new book
is the sickness is the system when
capitalism fails to save us from
pandemics or itself and you you make the
point in the book that i've been making
for some time which is
that the pandemic exposed the inherent
fragility
of many systems which we take for
granted this includes
the streams of income from our jobs
whatever they may be
this includes the food supply chain as
we very quickly saw in grocery stores
toilet paper the inability of government
our government others have moved far
more quickly but the inability of our
government to quickly react to changing
circumstances
give us the kind of big picture of what
what the takeaway should be
well i think it's a stark illustration
of something which
has been difficult for many americans to
get their
their heads around so let me be blunt
and make the point that the
the book makes uh in a variety of ways
if you think about it we all know that
we had a terrible virus back in 1918
killed 600 000 americans we know very
well how damaging viruses
are in recent years we have studied
murs sars ebola i mean
there is no excuse for a modern country
let alone a rich one let alone a an
economy with a well-developed
medical practice and education system
to be unprepared for a virus there
really is
no excuse and when you remember that an
economic system
if it has any priority the public health
of the people who live in it
has to be right up there number one two
or three
why in the world were we unprepared we
had companies that can produce
masks and gloves and ventilators and all
of that
but they didn't do it and i know why i'm
an economist what i study
it isn't profitable no company wants to
produce masks
uh by the millions store them in
warehouses around the country where the
population
is concentrated make sure that they are
clean
make sure that they don't deteriorate
replace those that do
watch the whole thing and then you never
know when the next virus will be
will you have to sit on all of this for
two years for six years
for 20 years so it's not profitable it's
not a rational
capitalist profit driven calculation to
make
so the companies didn't and we didn't
have the ventilators the gloves the
masks and all the rest
and there's no shorthand way of saying
it private capitalism
and the public health don't work
well together they don't solve the
problem
okay we could have had a secondary
solution
the government could have come in and
said what i just said
private capitalism is not capable of
making us prepared for a virus
so we're going to do it we're going to
buy the masks as fast as you produce
them
ditto the ventilators ditto the gloves
and then we're gonna store them at
taxpayer expense
in fact in warehouses and distribute
them
and monitor them and clean them and
replace them we'll do all that
because private capitalism fails the
government
is going to come in and compensate but
we didn't do that either
because our government is trapped in
this ideology
that somehow private capitalism does
everything
maximally efficiently maximally it's all
wrong
well they did have now they did have the
national stockpile right i mean in a
sense that's what it is it was
completely misdistributed
and they did nothing with it for months
but to some degree isn't that what the
national stockpile is
yes and and look we have plenty of
examples of where the government
can do it the best example that i use is
defense
right you know it's not profitable to
make a missile and store it for 10 years
or a gun or a ship or a plane but we do
what happens is the government comes
right in
buys the thing as fast as the defense
companies produce it
and then the government pays to store it
monitor it and clean it
so we know how to do it but it wasn't
done because we're so ideologically
blocked
that what we can do for defense we won't
actually do for our own
personal public health we've been
cutting back
on rural hospitals we've been coming
back on that stockpile
we have now shown ourselves to have
what i mean here's the statistic that i
think ends all conversation
the united states has four and a half
percent of the world's people and we
have 25
of the world's covet cases and covet
deaths
we're a rich country that is a statistic
that screams something fundamental is
wrong if a society with our capability
has such a record so on the economic
response
which countries did best in terms of
dealing with the financial insecurity
the job loss as a result of social
distancing measures are what what are
the examples we should look to
yeah i'm afraid that there again i have
bad news but it's a bad news it's also a
wake-up call
yeah the united states did not do well
let me give you the starkest example
in the united states over the last six
months
the richest people in the country gained
tens of billions
more of their wealth those numbers are
well known i won't repeat them
over the same period of time more than
50 million people
had to file for unemployment
compensation
either by the state or the federal
government i mean a starker rendition of
inequality
you could not have at the same time we
were all telling each other
this virus is a great danger to all of
us we
all have to work hard together we will
get through this together
yeah some people got through it together
by becoming richer
and an awful lot of people are getting
through it
by becoming poorer because of
unemployment why do i stress this
in the european countries it wasn't done
unemployment in italy
during the entire covid period was less
than it was a year before that when
there was no uh
coven german unemployment went from five
percent
roughly in march to six percent roughly
now in short in every major european
country they did not do
what the united states did they didn't
throw tens of millions of people
out of work throwing them on
unemployment
adding to their losses of unemployment
the
unspeakable anxiety of wondering whether
they never have a job again
whether the job they lost would be there
when they went back
looking for it which we all know
millions of them won't we already
know that um and so they're all
wondering is the roulette wheel gonna
come down and point on me
uh to add anxiety
to the worries about the illness to the
worries about managing your children who
can't go to school
your distance i mean it's unspeakable
and let me tell you why
in europe the reaction was so much
better
the european leaders whether they're
right wing left wing or in the middle
they know the following labor unions
socialist parties communist parties
they're much stronger in europe
than they are in the united states and
that's been true for a long time
and everyone there knows if you had
dared
throw tens of millions of working people
out of their jobs
out of the security of their jobs they
wouldn't have gone home
to watch tv they would have gone into
the streets
and they would have shut down those
economies way more totally
than any pandemic could and everyone
there knew it so here was the deal in
europe the government will help you
in your business but you cannot
fire anyone you get it
that's the condition and that was
accepted in europe
and that's how they've handled it here
in the united states
we don't have the political muscle on
the left
in the labor movement to create a
comparable
awareness so the trump administration
could
go ahead the democrats provided very
little
opposition even the afl-cio
hasn't had a demonstration to say this
is taking out the difficulties of a
virus
on the mass of people who have no guilt
whatsoever why are they singled out
why is it possible to impose
unemployment on 50 million people
while the richest people gain billions i
mean this is
beyond words and my book is an attempt
to try to get at how this came about and
how it works
so that people can contextualize these
awful results
yeah the book is the sickness is the
system when capitalism fails to save us
from pandemics or itself
we're going to go to a break on the tv
and radio show with professor richard
wolff but you'll be able to find our
entire conversation which will continue
on on the youtube channel
so in in looking forward now there for
months there's been this idea of another
so-called stimulus uh there have been
discussions about
will it happen won't it happen who's for
it who's against it we're
now 38 days or however many from a
presidential election
there's been a failure to do that second
stimulus
when you look at that what does that
failure
tell you about the bigger picture of how
elected officials are seeing this
pandemic
well it tells me a very sobering thought
that the kinds of calculations the
people in power make
simply do not take into account
not only the suffering of large numbers
of people
which is itself a serious problem of
disconnection
but they don't even take into account
the economic viability of this system
it gives me this amazing sense those of
us who
know and are willing to say it
ideologically
this capitalist system in the united
states is now
on government life support that has to
be understood
a couple of examples the federal reserve
has now started
buying corporate debt directly and
indirectly
massive amounts i don't know whether
americans really understand what that
means
it means every corporation in america
that has
any kind of economic problem they're
producing something that people don't
want or their technology is out of date
or they have bad relations with their
working people
whatever it is the cheapest
easiest way to solve the problem is to
go borrow money
to throw that money at it why because
the federal reserve is
literally creating the money and
charging you virtually zero
interest rate for it and when you borrow
from a bank
the bank simply turns around and sells
that corporate debt
to the federal reserve so in the end the
creditor of the american business
community
is the united states government which is
making that money available
and which is keeping interest rates down
you are
subsidizing the entire capitalist system
and as if that weren't enough you're
also dishing out
huge amounts of money to unemployment
compensation
for workers that are out of a job to all
kinds of special benefits during the
covet period
for given loans to small businesses etc
etc this is an economy that lives off
the government
therefore you cannot cut back the
support the government gives
because that teeter-totters the system
since that's what it's sitting on
when they decided not to renew the extra
600
per week for unemployment as of the end
of july
july 31st they were removing
one key support for this
economic system and the statistics
already show
that the upswing that was supposed to be
a recovery
is now on shaky ground no surprise
there i'm struck and i have to say this
i'm struck by a system that is at once
cruel to the people who deserve it least
and self-destructive in its
loyalty to an ideology that the
government should be not
doing things that it ought to obviously
do
during this period and i take both of
those things
as signs of serious long-term
economic decline and i think that's what
is the context for all of this yeah
our our next conversation should be a
deeper dive
into what we are being told about what
the recovery will look like
and and what actually is is more likely
to happen probably
probably for our next conversation we've
been speaking with economist richard
wolff the new book
is the sickness is the system when
capitalism
fails to save us from pandemics or
itself
uh as always uh very much appreciate
your time
thank you very much david and very much
appreciate the opportunity to talk with
you about these things